[Music]
jessica simpson is getting back to music
i'm a dreamer so i have more things to
do so
it's never i'm very happy but i am not
standing still on thursday the 41 year
old singer wowed fans with a cover of
nothing but thieves 2017 track particles
as well as a music video for her version
of the song
[Music]
jess's stripped down take on the track
is played on the piano and is more of a
ballad than the original version
[Music]
in the emotional video jess sings about
addiction driving someone she loves away
and wanting to be better for that person
[Music]
the song bird posted about the new music
video on instagram sharing this still
from the video and writing the whole
idea of music heals is an honest truth
to me this song saved a broken piece of
me i think everybody's careers have
their own unique stories you know the
song and music video's release comes
just two days after just teased
potential new music on instagram with
this snap and thursday's date 11 11. she
also shared this black and white pick of
a piano with the same caption
[Music]
of course the mom of three recently
celebrated four years of sobriety
posting this quote unrecognizable
throwback of herself on the morning she
decided to get sober the take my breath
away singer shared a lengthy caption
alongside the image which read in part
quote i knew in this very moment i would
allow myself to take back my light show
victory over my internal battle of
self-respect and brave this world with
piercing clarity i'm very like conscious
in my mind even if i'm not like speaking
it
um i'm like i can't believe that you
have to do this like i was disappointed
in myself but i would still pour the
drink
um because i didn't know how i would
make it through i didn't know that i
could actually be strong enough without
it and really i'm way stronger
without it and i didn't realize i
thought that that was gonna help me
through life i didn't know that it was
actually keeping me from living my life
jessica talked more about her decision
to quit drinking in her memoir open book
where she shared that a hazy halloween
in 2017 led her to quit for good jess
included six songs in the audiobook for
her memoir the first tracks she released
in a decade since a 2010 christmas album
and she opened up to et about how making
those six songs was a cathartic
experience amid her struggles with
alcohol the music is actually
everything that inspired me to
get sober and to write the book because
i realized when i was going down into my
studio even though i was in the comfort
of my own house
i
i had a drink
to numb
the pain that i was about to experience
to write
[Music]
you